בסוף אני אעשה לך קצת Fire Questions באנגלית, אבל...
וזה יהיה לסושל שלם, אבל בסוף יהיה לנו את הפרק וההקלטה בשפה שלנו.
אוקיי, נעשה את זה, מעולם.
עכשיו, איך אני אומר את השם שלך כמו שצריך?
אני...
זה אדיר, אני בחיים לא ראיתי מישהו כותב את זה ככה.
תקשיב, זה משהו שקומי שאני מדבר איתו, אומר לי, אף פעם לא ראיתי את זה, וזהו, בחיים לא השכיחו
את השם הזה יותר, כי זה שמש מגניבה.
וזהו, אתה נצח לזכור את זה עכשיו זה טריק כל המזכורות השם הזה, לעולם לא תשכח אותו
ניצן, וואו.
אני חולה.
אשכרה.
לאח שלי קוראים אור, והוא גר בניו יורק עשרים שנה, וכשהאנשים מיושלים אותו, מה זה שם, אז הוא
היה אומר, אני אור.
ואז הם אמרו, מה?
ואז הוא אמר, לא, לא, אני אור, כמו הקנג'ונקציה.
אז הוא, אז בלוחית רישוי של הרכב הראשון בפלו אלטו,
כשגרנו שם אז הוא היה...
היה לו, name is Or, like the conjunction.
אז אתה...
אני ניצן, אני מקורסן.
אחלה.
אדיר.
ניצן, איזה כיף שאתה מצטרף אליי, all the way, מה- East Coast.
תודה רבה ש...
שאתה לוקח את הזמן.
איזה כיף לי.
בכיף בכיף כיף כיף לפגש כיף לעשות שיחה במיוחד אחרי ג'רני משותף שעברנו דרך חלק גדול מהאותם
תוכניות
זה ממש נשמע שעברנו כאן, Teralel Paths, סופר מגניבים, וישמין, אם את שמעת את זה, אז ניצן ממש
התגעגע לזה שאתה אתבר אותי עם כוכבים באותו תקופה, אמרתי לו כמה כיף היה לנו איתך, אבל ניצן,
אנחנו כאן כדי לדבר על Serious Stuff, Cyber Security, זה אחד התחום המכים מגניבים לא הטים
שיש היום.
אנחנו, זה לא חדש בתעשייה שלנו, ואני חושב שזה כן עובר אבולוציה וזה עובר מתשורתי
וטרנספורמטיה.
אתה חי את זה המון זמן, אז אני ממש מחכה לשמוע קצת את הפרספקטיבה שלך.
מהמון היבטים, גם מהיבט היום של אפלקיישן סקיוריטי עם אוקס סקיוריטי, ובעיקר גם, אתה יודע, יש
המון טרנדים והמון דברים שאני שומע, גם בעצמי מסיסוים שמדברים גם עליו, בעיקר על העניין של
פריוריטיזיישן ומה לא לעשות.
כשנכנסים לאתר, הדבר הראשון זה אנחנו באים לתקוף את החמש אחוז שבאמת כן צריך לתקוף.
אז זה מדבר לה הרבה מהמסערים שאני שומע בעצמי מהלקוחות.
וממש כיף שאתה פה, אז תודה שהצטרפת עליי.
בכיף בכיף, כיף לראות אותו
ספר לי איך התחלת בכלל בעולם הסקיוריטי.
וואו, אוקיי, בסייבר, בחלולתו התחלתי במשרד הביטחון בכלל ותקופות מאוד מעניינות, למדנו שם
מלא, מלא, מלא, מלא דברים מעניינים ואז הקמתי את הסטארט-אפה הראשון את העשייה השונה לחלולתי
מאשר היום הרבה פחות מפותחת, היה התחילת שנת אלפיים ממש כל הדברים שקשורים בפיתוחים ואינטרנט
הכל היה כאילו כל כך...
בו סרילום אתה יום פגישות היית צריך ללכות ולפגוש אותו ולטוס אליו ולא היה זום, אין כזה דבר,
צריך לצום עם לקוח, אז זה לא היה קיים אז...
אז היה מאוד מאוד שני כל הקונספט של פרי קוביד שכאילו אתה ממש צריך לטוס ללקוח אז זה היה נורא
מעניין, ואז כאילו, בצד שני, אתה יודע, לא היה כך הרבה חברות סייבר ובתמורה אתה מגיע לקוח, אז
אתה הייתה הוונדו
כי לא היה עוד ונדורי, אף עוד לא היה מגיע לאותו לקוח.
אז סטאפסטה דורם מעניינת, היית בא לקונפרנצ'ז וכולם היו מתפעלים, והיום אתה מגיע לקונפרנצ'ז
וכולם מסתכלים, אומרים, ראינו את זה בוובסייט, אתה ועוד כמה, מה אתה שונה?
אז התחום השתנה לחלוטין בשנים.
לגמרי, לגמרי.
אוקיי, ובעצם, איך אז אתה התחלת משרד הביטחון, קמת ונדיום סקיורטי, מה זה ונדיום?
ונדיום זה מתכת מאוד מאוד קשה אז...
אוהב דברים קשים קודם קודם מתכת ועכשיו שור
אז שורחיה אחרת לחבלותין זה כאילו משהו אקטיבי, חורש את השדות, עושה את העבודה הקשה בשבילך לא
קשור לבנאדיום.
לא, בנאדיום זה היה דרך לבוא להסתכל על בעיות שהיו בחברות שעבדנו איתם בזמנו שהם היו למלא מלא
בעיות באינטפוינט והם לא הבינו את הפרטים של מה שקורה שם.
היה שחקנים יותר אינקמבד בזור האינטפוינט היה מקפי, היה סימנטק
וכל הנושא הזה של EDR, מה שהיה מתפתח, היה אז שאלות אחרות לחלוטין, של מה בפועל קורה על תחנות
קצה.
וזה מה שעשינו אז.
והנחבות שכאילו השוק עבר כל כך בטעפוחות, כשאתה מסתכל על הטכנולוגיות ואיך מגיעים אל הכוחות,
ו-AI ו-Cloud וה-on-premise לעומת appliances, כל כך הרבה שינויים שעברו, שאתה מסתכל על
החברות הקודמות, זאת אומרת, אין שום קשר בין החברות שהיו פעם...
לחברות שיום הן לא קשורות אחת לשנייה זה ממש סדק רב אחרי החלוטין
ממש ואז הכניסה לצ'קפוינט
אז שקפוינט היה קודם כל שקפוינט חברה מדהימה.
חברה שאתה הצטרפתי לה שהייתה סאב מיליארד, ועשינו את העלייה שם לשני מיליארד דולר במחירות,
ואתה רואה את העוצמם בפנים, כאילו יש שם אנשים פשוט מדהימים, גם באיכויות, גם באופי שלהם.
זה חברה כאילו, למדתי ממני כך הרבה דברים, שזה פשוט מדהים.
כאילו היא פשוט.
‫בספר, עבורי ההפרטיה, ‫בספר הכי מדהים בעולם.
וואו.
מה, תן לי כמה זיכרונות...
זיכרונות טובים משם, ויכל זאת, 10 שנים כמעט.
תראה, היה לנו כמה מוצרים שבהם הצלחנו לעשות ממש Exponential Growth בתוך Checkpoint שממש,
אתה רואה את Exponential Growth אתה רואה איך השוק שואב את זה זה פשוט היה מדהים אתה לומד טוב
מאוד איפה יש לך בעוד Quality ואיך תקן אותם אתה לומד טוב מאוד, במקרה שלנו, חטיבה גדלה להיות
איזה כמה מאוד טובות של אנשים איך הנהל בסקייל זה המון דברים שכאילו הם
הם לקחים מדהימים ויותר מזה גם יש לך אנשים מדהימים כמו דן ודורית וגיל שגם לבוא חלק הגדול
מהתהליך וידעות את עצות והיה פשוט הענוג
איזה אדיר.
דורית ממש הייתה פה בתוכנית הזאת, ממש לפני כמה ימים.
אז זה ממש חוויה היה לשמוע גם על ההקמה של שקפוינט ועל ה-27 שנים, משהו כזה, שזה כבר רץ.
קח אותי, אז קח אותי רגע חזרה ל-2021, ואיפה אתה נמצא, איפה העולם נמצא, שאתה מגיע לקונביקשון
הזה סביב האפלקיישון סקיוריטי, מה הקונטקסט שאנחנו חיים בו?
אז, אפליקיישן סקיוריטי זה אחד הדברים שבצ'קפוינט היה עבורי, אחד הדברים הכואבים.
למה כואבים?
הייתם שחרר מוצר, מגיעים החבר של הפנטסט, ויש שם בחור, מקסים וחבר בשם עודד ואנונו, שיום אחד
הראה לי מוצר שולחים שחרר אותו, איך הוא מתעלל במוצר ועושה שם כמה דברים מביכים.
כמובן לפני שיחור, כמובן לפני הרבה מאוד דברים אחרים, ו...
פתאום אמרתי, תקשיב, תדעי, תיקנו חלק מהכליים הקיימים באפסק וכאילו, אין פה כלום, הם לא גילו
פה כלום משמעותי.
ופתאום הבנו שבעצם, יודע, העולמות של העתיד איפה הוא נמצא, הוא לאט לאט התרחק מעולמות של
להיות נטווק ולהיות באמצע, הוא נהיה במה יש לך בתוך הקוד עצמו ומה יש לך באינטפוינט שצורך.
ותדח באמצע קצת, התעוצה בתוכו הפסיקה.
כלומר, השוק הפסיק לגדול שמה, הוא התפתח מאוד לקלאד, שזה איפה אתה מריץ, לאפליקיישן שתמיד היה
שמה, כי מפתחים מזיזים את הדברים אחרו הקלאנים, ואמרו, טוב, תקשיב, צריך להכתפל בבעיה הזאת,
כל החברות שהיו באותו שלב בשוק התעסקו בכל מיני דברים שהם מאוד בנהלים, כמו open source
security, or static code analysis, והערך היה כל כך נמוך.
כשסתכלנו על זה ואמרנו,
רוב הדברים שיש פה פשוט לא מביאים שום ערך הייתי מביא את זה למפתחים והם היו חזרים ומסבירים
לי שבתוך עשר בעיות שכותב קריטיקל 0 % מתוכם רלוונטי זה לא מחובר לאינטרנט וזה בכלל דפריקייטד
למה אתם ראים לי פרויקטים שהם דפריקייטד וזה בכלל קוד ניסוי זה בטסט פרודג'ק אפלימי שלנו זה
בכלל לא בקוד פרודקשן והוא כזה והוא כזה זה היה פגישות נורא מביכות שאתה יושב שם ואתה מנסה
לטווח בין סקיוריטי שדיווחו אליי לבין המפתחים שדיווחו אליי ואתה אומר תקשיבו זה לא הגיוני
השיחה פה היא לא נכונה ואז אתה בסוף הרבעון אתה עושה סיכום כמה כוח אדם השקענו בלתקן בעוד
סקיוריטי ואתה מגיע למספרים אסטרונומיים של שעות אדם ואתה מבין שהם לא תיקנו שום בעיה אמיתית
הם לא הוריתו שום סיכון אמיתי, כלום
ואז כאילו התחיל הרעיון עצמו להתהוות שאומר, יש פה בעיה.
עכשיו, קצת נושאו כי זה לא היה הרעיון המקורי, אבל לאט לאט אתה חוזרים פלשבקים, ותוך כדי
שחוזרים פלשבקים אתה אומר, טוב, הבנתי למה צריך לעשות את זה בצורה הזאת, ואיך לעשות את זה
ככה, ואז למעשה התפתח הסיפור עצמו.
אבל...
ואתה יודע, הפער שאתה מראיתם הוא היה בעיקר באיכות של האנליזה, בדינמיות שלה, בעומק שלה,
בפריוריטיזיישן של הקריטיקלנס של ה-Threats.
זאת אומרת, איפה היה בעצם הגאפ?
העניין הזה של let's build applications the right way, היה...
עולם שהוא ידוע קיים.
מה...
למה היה הגאפ הזה מלכתחילה?
אז אם אתה זוכר, לפני כמה דקות דיברנו על ונדים, החברה הקודמת וכמה היא שונה ממה שצריך היום
החברות שנמצאות בשוק הזה של application security רובם, המוחלט פשוט נמצאות עדיין בעידן הקודם
הם חושבות waterfall, חושבות ישן, הם חושבות זקן הם מתאימות לדברים שלא זזים מהר היום הפיתוח
הוא לא כזה הפיתוח נראה אחרת, הפיתוח הוא אני צריך להבין קונטקסט מלא ואתה צריך לעשות לי
עבודה קלה
וכל החברות האלה עסוקות בלייצר חייר רשימות כמה שיותר רוקות כי פעם ככה אני רע פיוסי אתה הבאת
לי 3,000, הוא הבאת לי 4,000 4,000 יותר טוב מזמן 3,000 אז פעם זה מה שרצינו, שיהיה כמה שיותר
דיטקשן ואז יש את המשפט האלמוטי של תיזהר עם מה שאתה מבקש ובסוף תקבל אותו ואתה מקבל את 4,000
או 40,000 או 400,000 ואז אתה אומר מעולם, אתה עושה חשבון ואתה אומר למפתח לוקח
יום עבודה נגיד שזה יום עבודה לסגור בעיה ויש לי פה 400 אלף אז אם אני אסגור את כל הפיתוח
לרבעון הקרוב אז אולי אני אכסה חצי ממה שכתוב לי לעשות זה לא ריאלי כן אני לא אסגור את הרבעון
ואני לא אעשה את זה ככה אני צריך לשאול את עצמי מה הולך להרוג אותי ולטפל בו
ובתוך כל הרע של החברות הדור הראשון של המוצרים האלה אי אפשר היה להבין את זה מה שאתה מקבל זה
כזה מין משפט קריפטי שאומר יש לך SQL injection בשורה 4,045 שאתה רואה אז אתה אומר אוקיי בוא
נראה אות מה יש שם אתה מסתכל על זה ויש שם שילטת SQL ואז אתה מנסה להבין אבל כאילו מה לא בסדר
בשלטה הזאת עכשיו שאתה עושה את זה כמפתח אחד זה סבבה אבל שיש לך חמש עוד מפתחים
ויש לך תוכן גם ג'ונירים ואתם מסתכלים עליהם, אבל מה לא בסדר שמה?
ואתה לא יודע להסביר להם את זה ואז צריך מישהו של Upset שסביר להם ואז אין של Upset שכאן
עושים ואתם מבטיח תוכנית של Security Champions ואין להם מבין מה רוצים עם זה נהיה בלאגן אחד
גדול אז מה לא בסדר בחברות האלה?
הם בנו את כל התיאוריה שלהם שריליס היה Waterfall אתה מאפיין בחודש הראשון ומבטח בחודש 2, 3,
מבטיח לדבר בחודש 5, מוריד ה-QA בחודש 8 ומשחרר בחודש 11 ואז יש לך זמן לבדיקות איפשהו פשוט
עולם לא עובד ככה רוב החברות שיש משחררות כמה פעמים ביום ואז אין את המקום הזה וכל הקונספט
פשוט נשבר ונשארו מוצרים משנים וזה היה the best of the industry can offer ושם היה לנו את
ה-conviction שאמרנו פשוט חייבים לשנות את זה
אתה חיפשת להקים מזמן בתקופה הזאת או שאתה הגעת פשוט לקולמינציה של תובנות סביב הבעיה וסביב
ההזדמנות, שעמרתם, אוקיי, זה הזמן.
תראה, זה לא שכאילו ברגע שיצאנו היה לנו את הקונביקשן הזה.
אתה אוסף מלא מלא פרטים של דאטה תוך כדי.
מה זה אומר?
זה אומר שיצאנו, אתכם אוכלים רעון אחר.
ולאט לאט אתה אוסף את האינפוט, אתה מגיע לאנשים ואתה אומר להם, מה לתחיל הכיוון הזה, הכיוון
הזה, הכיוון הזה?
ובסופו של דבר אתה מחפש אותם משהו שאתה אומר, תקשיב, אם אתה מצליח להראות את הדבר הזה, אני
מוכן להתקין.
וכל הדלוק קיבלנו את התשובות האלה בצורה שיטתית.
‫וכיפסנו עדיין איפה אנחנו נמצאים.
‫והפרויקט הראשון, ‫זה היה פרויקט שכאילו יצאנו ‫ואנסינו לעשות אותו, ‫לקחנו שישה שבועות
להבין ‫שאנחנו דוחפים ‫וכרצה לשני לא רוצה למשוך.
‫אז זה נחת את הרעון הזה, ‫ואז הגענו לרעון הנוכחי, ‫הבנו טוב מאוד איפה יש בעיה ‫ומה צריך
לעשות איתה.
איך המשיכה הזאת נראית?
‫תראה, היום יש לנו למעלה ‫ממטיים לקוחות בשנתיים וקצת של מכירות, ‫ואיך זה נראה?
‫זה נראה שאתה מגיע לשיחה ראשונית ‫ועל לקוחות אתה רואה ‫איך הם מדברים על הבעיה הקיימת שלהם
‫ועל הוונדור הקיים שלהם, ‫ובגדול הם אומרים לך, תקשיב, ‫אנחנו נסמך לפרד ממנו ‫עם מה שאתה
אומר הוא אמיתי.
‫עכשיו...
ברגע שאתה שומע את המשפט הזה ועל הכוח אומר, דמו יפה, אבל אצלי זה סיבה מסובכת.
למה מסובכת?
כי אצלי הכול עובד אחרת.
וחלק הגדול מהסיפור בעולם הזה זה עולם עם המון המון המון מקרה קיצון וכל הכוח הוא שונה, יש לו
שפה שונה, יש לו די פלויימן שונה, יש לו קלאנט שונה, יש לו די פלויימן ציי סי די שונה.
כמות הווריאציות היא פשוט אינסופית ופשוט מאוד...
אנחנו באנו במקום שלמדנו לעשות הרבה מאוד עבודה קשה בצפר, צ'קפוינט הוא בצפר מאוד מאוד טוב
לשיש מקומות שפשוט צריך לעשות עבודה שיטתית וקשה וזה מה שמביא אותך למיצחון.
ואנו צוות שהביא אותנו בצ'קפוינט לנצח את המבחנים הכי קשים בעולם כמו NSS ולהיות מקום ראשון
בצורה שיטתית.
וזה פשוט ניהן של מטודולוגיה של לעשות העבודה בצורה טובה וזה מה שלקחנו אותנו בדי.אן.אי שלנו.
עכשיו, אתם הקמתם את החברה בסוף 21, אבל שנה לאחר מכן הכל השתנה.
זאת אומרת, העולם השתנה.
הוא השתנה גם אצלכם, באותו תקופה.
זאת אומרת, מה קרה כשאתם ראיתם את כל מה שקורה עם ה-LLMs?
‫תראה, LLM התחל לפגוש אותו ‫בצורה אמיתית, ‫בגנטרית 23 התחל לפגוש אותו ‫בצורה רצינית.
‫עכשיו, בהתחלה זה היה ‫נורא נורא נאיבי.
‫כמות ה-illucination הייתה לא הגיונית, ‫וזה עוד לא היה...
‫good enough, ‫אבל ראינו שיש בתוך הכמה ‫את הדברים שהם ממש ממש טובים.
‫זה לוקח המון שעות שמשחק ‫בשביל להבין את זה, של...
נגיד, recombinant בקוד הוא מעולה, בלמצוא בעיות בקוד הוא די גרוע.
בלכתוב קוד הוא לא טוב, אבל אם אתה לוקח קוד קיים ואתה אומר לו תעשה את השינוי הזה והזה ונותן
לו few shots learning על מה אתה רוצה, הוא לא רב בלקח את הקוד הקיים שלך ולעשות לו אינטגרציה
עם פתרון בית ספר שדומה למקרה הזה.
אז אתה בעצם כאילו צריך לעזור למגבלות שיש לו היום למה קורה בחוץ.
עכשיו...
אלה להם אחד הדברים הצחיקים בתוכו שאתה בעצם אומר מאיפה אלה להם יודע את הדברים האלה?
זה הרי נראה כמו קסם ואתה אומר מאיפה יודעים את הדברים האלה?
טוב לקחו את המקורות שיש שם לאופן סורס ולמדו מהם הבא שאופן סורס נורא נורא שונה מאפליקציות
שהרגולים כותבים אופן סורס כתוב או נבנה להיות מודולרי או נבנה להיות מודול שמישהו עושה לו
אינקלוד אפליקציה לא עושה לה אינקלוד
היא צריכה לרוץ, צריכה לחשוב על OMS ועל API, ועל הדיפלויימט ועל הקלאד ועל איפוסטרקציה ועל
קוד ומולטי מיינטנרס ויש שם הבעות תחלות לחלוטין.
באופן סורס מצד אחד יש לך טיעוד של וונביליטי, אבל הם מאוד לימטד.
אז בעצם למדת משהו על אפליקיישן, אבל למדת סוג מסוים של אפליקיישן, של מודולים.
ואז אתה מגיע לסיומש בהם בעולם אמיתי, ואלה אליהם פשוט לא טוב בזה.
עכשיו אתה יודע, אנחנו רואים את זה היום עם כל מיני מוצרים שכותבים בבורך קוד, כל מיני ניו
ג'ן IDEs שכותבים בבורך קוד, ואתה מנסה להבין אם כאילו הם עושים יותר צויות סקירוטי או פחות
צויות סקירוטי, ואתה אומר, הם עושים בדיוק אותו כמות.
ואיך זה יכול להיות והתשובה היא שהם למדו את התאום קוראות ב-outsecurity כחלק מה-codebase
שלהם ועכשיו הם זה מה שהם כותבים
איך באמת הצורך בעולמות התוכן של Oxi או פתרונות Oxi, איך זה השתנה בעקבות הטרנד עכשיו של...
סליחה לא Oxi, Oxi Security, גם Oxi אחלה חברה, וידר, אחלה, שלום, אבל איך הפתרונות של Oxi
Security, איך הפתרונות האלה השפיעו מבחינת הטרנד שהשתנה, שמפתחים משתמשים בקרסר...
שלא לדבר על וייב קודינג עכשיו, איך זה משנה את הפרדיגמה של פתרונות כמו אוקס סקיורטי.
קודם כול התשובה היא, יש שני דברים שונים שיקרו בתעשייה, קוראים ויקרו.
הראשון זה אם אתה עדיין כותב קוד, יש לך בגדול את אותן בעיות.
כל מה שאתה כותב קוד זה אותן בעיות.
הפנדמנטלס קוראים לתוכן את הבעיות ולכן תוצרים קוראים לתוכן את הבעיות.
זה לא משתנה שום דבר.
אני חושב שאנחנו נגיעים למקום טיפה שונה בעולמות האג'נטיק.
שבו בעצם אתה אומר אני כבר לא אכתוב קוד,
אני אתן את המודול שלי, אני קח את ה-API וייתן את ה-DATA לאיזשהו מנגנון AI, טענתי אותו
איזשהו Word document וה-Word document הזה הוא בעצם הלוגיקה ושם אתה הולך לקבל דברים אחרים
מחלוטים.
שם אתה הולך לקבל פשוט סט חדש של בעיות, שהן הרבה יותר קרות לעולמות הפרוד מאשר לסקיול
אינג'קשן, שבעצם, בכלל זה בתור שילוב של פרוד וסקיול אינג'קשן, שאתה אומר איך אני עושה אין
פרומט אינג'קשן,
אבל חכם.
אז אני חושב שאנחנו יכולים לראות הרבה יותר מהסוג הזה שזה התקרב הרבה יותר לעולמות הפרוד מאשר
לעולמות הטקניקל אקספליטיישם.
ולא ספק אתה רואה שם את כל המקרים שקורים עם איך תמשכנע האיי לא לעשות דברים שהוא לא אמור
לעשות ואיך תמשכנע האיי לתת לך דיסקאונס בתורבוטים.
ראיתי את הדוגמה של ה-Volkswagen לדעתי, שלמכרה ב-100 דולר, שזה נהדר.
אז יש מלא מלא דוגמאות כאלה.
עכשיו, אתה יודע, היה את האתגר לא מזמן של איך אתה משכנע את AI לתת לך מידע שהוא לא אמור לתת.
ואתה ראית, שלוש ועוד אנשים ניסו, ואז פתאום אחד הצליח למצוא איזה כיוון מעניין כאילו לספר
סיפור.
עכשיו, אתה אנחנו לא מבינים את הטכנולוגיה הזאתי עד הסוף, אף אחד לא מבין אותה עד הסוף.
ואם יש לי מישהו איזשהו motion או notion שאנחנו באמת, יום אחד נבין את הטכנולוגיה הזאתי
באמת, אנחנו הולכים לכיוון להפוך.
לגמרי
זה ככל שהם מתווספים יותר ויותר שכבות ויותר לופים בתוך המנועים האחרוי הקלעים אנחנו מציעים
את עצמנו במקומות שהלוגיקה הישרה כבר לא עובדת יותר ואתה יודע, מתחילים לצאת כל מיני מקומות
שבהם אתה מתחיל לראות בייס בתוך משינלרנג כדי להגן על החלטות קודמות שהם עשו ואז אתה אומר, מה
מרחק מפה לסקיינט?
כבר לא רחוק
במיוחד עם הפרסום שהיה לא מזמן על ה-Humanoids שכבר עושים מכזה מין שמנים שמתכווצים ואתם
עושים כזה, טוב, זה כבר קריפי לגמרי.
ממש.
לאן התחום הזה הולך לדעתך האבסקס?
זאת אומרת, אם אנחנו מסתכלים על זה שנה, שנתיים קדימה, מה...
Where is it converging?
תראה, UPSEC כשוק הוא שוק עם אחד השוקים הכי פעילים שראיתי עד היום.
יש המון חברות שפעילות בו, יש המון אינוביישן שקורה בו, יש המון עומק שהוא אונקספלורד, נגיד,
בניגוד ללמוד הרשת שבהם די מציניות מה שאתה יכול ללמוד מהרשת.
בקוד יש כל הזמן עוד ועוד עומק שאתה יכול ללמוד.
יש מה הנגזרות הראשונות והשניות של הקוד עצמו, יש שם המון המון המון דברים.
מעניינים שבישל זה, אתה לא יכול לקחת כזה ממוצר אופן סורס ולומר, הרצי מוצר אופן סורס ועשיתי
סטטיק קודנאליסי, אתה צריך להבין את הקוד עצמו ומה המשמעות שלו ואיזה יפה יחושף אותו ובעצם אם
מגעתי לפה, להזדת את הבסוי הגיע ומה הוא יעשה זה כמעט אין סופי עם אחד העומק שיש, זה כמו שפת
פיתוח, היא כאן וספתוח, אתה יכול עושה את מה שאתה רוצה וזה אנחנו מגנים היום על כמות אדירה
שמפתחים ואתה מסתכל סתם בסטטיסטיקה אופטימיות שלנו כמה הקוד של א' דומה ל-ב'
כל אחד לוקח את זה למקום כל כך שונה שזה קריאטיב, זה לא אינג'יניריק בפועל אז לדעתי העומק
שמור אין סופי, זה ימשיך להתפתח בכיוונים האלה וככל שיבור הזמן נראה עוד שיטות ועוד כיוונים
ועוד בעיות כמו שלפני ארבע שנים אף אחד לא התייחס לפאספורד אמבדדן קוד והיום זה כולם יודעים
שזה בעיה נוראית ובמשל 20 שנה כולם חיו יופי עם הדבר הזה, לא הייתה שום בעיה עם זה
נגמר
ולאט לאט אתה יכול להגיד כל פעם שיש איזשהו טרנט שעולה באותו רבעון, אתה סוגר אותו ורבעון
אחרי זה יש באחר את החלוק.
תגיד, יש אלמנט של חוויית המשתמש שמשתנה מהצד של המפתחים בהקשרים של אפליקיישנס סקיוריטי,
כלומר כל השיףט לפט מובמנט והציפייה מסיסויים שיותר ויותר אחריות תשאב אצל המפתחים.
אני מניח שאוקס סקיוריטי יש לחלק בעצם בשיףט לפט מובמנט הזה, נכון?
תראה, שיפט לפט זה טרם מאוד מלבל כי אין לו הגדרה ממש טובה ולכן שיפט לפט נשמע לכולם כמו אני
אעביר את הבעל למפתחים עכשיו המשמעות של זה אומר בסופו של דבר זה תאפשר למפתחים לעשות את זה
אבל חלק עוד מהדברים שקוראים בפיתוח זה אם מישהו לא דוחף הדבר לא ינתחף
תחשב על זה שנחת שכראש צוות פיתוח ומפתח אתה כל הזמן נמצא בלחץ של פרודקט מנג'מנט אומרים
לעשות ככה והריליס מנג'מנט אומר ככה והריליס בתעריך כזה והתוכן צריך להיות ככה ויש חגים ויש
אקטיביטי ויש את הבית ויש עוד דברים שאני רוצה לעשות בחיים ובסופו של דבר, סקיוריטי נכנס כמו
באגים אחרים כמו בעיית פרופורמנס כמו בעיות אחרות ואז
יש לך בעצם תחרות פנימית על משאבים בין...
כאילו הם אמרו לי שיש לי בעיה בטקסט, יש לי טייפו מביך, ויש לי פה איזשהו בעיה את סקיוריטי
שהיא לא חמורה, אין שם משהו קריטי שמסכן אותנו, מה אני אעשה קודם.
וכאילו יש אקוסי שצריך להבין אותו איך את הגורם הדבר הזה לקרות.
השיף טלאפט בבנליות שלו אמר, אל תשלח את הבעיה לאפליקיישן סקיוריטי, שלח אותה למפתח.
עכשיו ראינו הרבה מאוד מהמתחרים מהדור הראשון מנסים לעשות את הדבר הזה ופותחים Gira Tickets
או פותחים Pull Request לפתחים והוא אומרים רק תעשר את זה ואז אתה מתחבר למקומות שיהיו בזה
Vendor קודם ואתה רואה שמה 115,000 Gira Tickets שהם Duplicated אחד עם השני אותו שפה מזה עזר
כמו קודם אותם בעיות כמו קודם וכזה אתה סתכל אתה אומר אני מבין למה יש פה 115,000 Tickets
ש-They're going nowhere
או פול ריקוויסט שכאילו הם קיבלו את השם אצל חלק מהמלכוחות בתור זומבי פול ריקוויסט שכאילו
לעולם אף אחד לא יגע בהם אז גם זה יש מה הרבה מאוד עניין של פסיכולוגיה שלך תיכול לעזור ולא
איך תיכול כמו שקראו את זה, חלק מקומות, to shit left זה לא פשוט תעביר את הטיקט זה תחשוב על
זה איך אתה עוזר לאנשים באמת
לפתור את הבעיה ובשביל זה צריכים לקרות כמה דברים צריך להיות trust שהם אומרים משהו הוא אמיתי
וזה קשה
מייצרים את זה?
אז אני אתן לך דוגמה שחצי שנה בהכפנים עלי תוך אוקס, בא אלינו מישהו ואמרנו, תקשיבו, הדיטקש
נכון, במקרה לחלוטין, אני עשיתי לתזווריפיקיישן וזה נכון, אבל היה לי מאוד קשה להאמין לכם
מהתחלה.
הוא אוקיי, נשמע טוב, אבל כאילו אמרנו את זה, אתה יודע, הוא אומר, למה אתה לא מוכרח לי שזה
אמיתי?
אמרנו, מה זה אומר, לא מוכרח לך שזה אמיתי?
הוא אומר...
הסברת לי עכשיו איך עשית את החישוב מאחורי הקלעים שזה חשוב למה שלא תראה לי, זה תן לי את
ההוכחות עצמם תראה לי שזה מחובר לאינטרנט אני לא מאמין לך אלא אם כן תמראה לי אוקיי, נראה לך
את זה ואז ישבנו עם תראה, בתור זמן היה לנו כמה עשרות לקוחות או כמה עשרות דיזיין פרטנרס כבר
ישבנו אותם ואמרנו, תקשיבו אם אני מראה לכם ככה וככה קחו את זה למפתחים, תאמרו לי איך הפידבק
שחוזר
וכשראינו שעל חלק מהדברים זה עובד עליהם, זה הנקודה שפשוט זזנו יותר ויותר לכיוונים האלה.
ואז נכנס הדי.אן.איי שלנו לומר, אי אפשר לומר, נגיד חלק מהמסך קנימי המשוק, אומרים כזה מין,
אם זה חשוף לאינטרנט, תן 3 % אקסטרה, ואם זה ככה, תן עוד 4 % אקסטרה.
והציון הסופי שלך הוא 79.
ואז אתה בא ואומר, ואז זה 79, איך אני מוכרח את זה לאודיטור?
איך אני מוכרח לדיבלופר ש79 זה טוב?
אולי תשאים זה טוב?
וכך שהבר הזמן התבשה על התובנה שדברים צריכים להיות מאוד מאוד אבסולוטיים מאוד חדים, אין מקום
לאמביגויטי וזה לקחנו הרבה זמן להבין את הדבר הזה שזה שוק שצריך להיות בו מול אנשים מאוד מאוד
חכמים, דיברלפרס ומול אקסק שגדלנו להתנמדו להיות צינים בעקבות העבודה המפתחים ואתה צריך
להתברג שם ולתת להם עזרה אמיתית ולא לקשות עליהם ג'רני מאוד מפקח
יש זאת אומרת יש מערכת יחסים גם ברמת הברנד שנבנית למול המפתחים עצמם זאת אומרת המפתחים
מכירים את אוקס ויש להם אינטראקציה איתכם
תראה, אנחנו משתדלים שלו, אנחנו משתדלים מאוד לעבוד עם האנשי האפליקיישן סקיוריטי ולדיבלופרס
להיות כמה שפחות רחוקים מהעין שלהם הסיבה לזה היא קשוטה בסופו של דבר כמפתחים באים אליך כל
מיני אנשים ברגון ואומרים לך תתחבר לג'ירה, תתחבר למערכת הזאתית, תתחבר למערכת הזאתית, תתחבר
למערכת הזאתית ואתה מוטה את עצמך עם 20 מערכות שונות שאתה אומר אני רק צריך להתחבר ולשים שומר
שק את הבוקס פה וזה מתרד
אתה אפילו לא יודע מה הקרידנצ'ה שלך, אתה לא יודע למה צריך להתחבר לשם, אתה לא זוכר מה הסדר
זה לא כיף כי אנחנו עושים לעבוד על התשתיות הקיימות שלהם להיות כמה שיותר נייטיב בתוך הכלים
והתהליכים הקיימים שלהם לא יצטרך לזכור דברים, לא יצטרך לעבוד מול אינטרפייס חדש הכל בתוך
הדברים שמכירים הכל מאוד מאוד אינטואיטיבי שאנחנו לא נהיה נטל שצריך לזכור, שאנחנו נהיה משהו
שהוא קל לטיפול קל לפיוסי קל להם להבין
שלא צריך איזשהו enablement זה מאוד מאוד קריטי
תגיד, אחרי כל השנים האלה, מה מרגש אותך עדיין בתחום של סקיורטי?
המכירות זה תמיד תחום שמרגש.
יש את השלב שאתה אומר איך אני נהיה יותר טוב.
בסופו של דבר אנחנו עשוי מסתכלים על התהליכים שלנו ועל הגידול שלנו וכמה אנחנו משתפרים ואיזה
סוג לקוחות ומה ה-engagement וזה מאוד נושמעותי לראות את זה.
בסופו של דבר לנצח את עצמך בעריוון הקודם ולומר אני מבין איך התחיל תהליך השיבה שסבירנו מה
צריך להיות טוב ועשינו אותו והשתפרנו.
רבעון אחר רבעון, ואתה כל רבעון רואה את הדבר הזה.
זה תהליך שהוא קשה, זה תהליך קשה כל הזמן לבדנות את עצמך מהתחלה ולהבין בעצם שדברים שבנית
לפני שני רבעונים כבר לא טובים, כי אתה גודל מהר.
זה מאוד מאוד כיף לראות את זה, אבל זה מאוד מרגש לראות שזה עובד.
ריגוש הזה אבל גם מגיע עם העובדה שלא כל דבר שאתה עושה עובד.
אז לצערי הרב, ככל שהנפילה ברבעון הקודם יותר קשה, הצלחה ברבעון הזה היא יותר טובה.
אז אתה מגיע לצוות, לא לכולם כל הזמן, כל רבעון הוא עומדים איפשהו רבעונים שהם פחות טובים, מה
לעשות כאילו גדלנו, גדלנו לא כמו שרצינו ואז אתה אומר סבבה, הנה הלקחים שלי מתוך זה זה מה
שנעשה רבעון הבא יותר טוב כולם מסיימים את המשחק, חוזרים לחדר עלדבשה עושים את ה-Dbrief
ויוצאים די חדשה עוד פעם חזקים יותר ואתה רואה שהתהליך הזה שגם הצוות כבר עושה אותו פנימית
ועוד מרגיש לירות
יש אלמנטים בעולם הסקיוריטי שמיוחדים לסייבר שגורמים לך להישאר בו כל כך הרבה זמן, או צורה
שאתה רואה את זה, מתפתח ששומרת אותך עם תשוקה על התחום הזה?
סייבר עם הכללותו, וואו, זה תחום שכאילו הוא לא, הוא לא הוצר לרגע.
זה ממש תחום שזז כל הזמן, הוא כל הזמן דוחף תוכנים חדשים, כל הזמן מזית תוכנים חדשים, הוא כל
הזמן, אתה לא יכול לעצור.
אתה בסופו של דבר משחק מול פעם אחת מול אדופשן בשוק ופעם שנייה מול אדוויסריז.
עכשיו, אדוויסריז, היינו עוקבים אחרי קבוצות גדולות של אדוויסריז, ואתה מסתכל מה הם עושים.
וזה די מדהים.
כאילו, אתה מסתכל על כמות הכסף שמגלגלים.
אתה לא תקשיב, שמגלגלים עשרות מיליונים של דולרים בשנה לקבוצה של חמישה עד שבעה אנשים.
וואו, זה אינסנטיב גדול לעשות דברים.
בדיוק השבתי פה עם אישם ששתבאתי כשעשו סקר ואמרו אם אנחנו נסחום את כל הכסף שחקרים או תוקפים
אדברסרי זושים אז זאת יהיה מדינה עם הכלכלה השלישית בגודלה בעולם
כן, זה...
תראה, בסופו של דבר יש לך היום, אני לא יודע אם זה אלפים כבר או עשרות אלפים של קבוצות פעילות
עכשיו, רובם אנחנו לא שמים כי הם באמת לא טובים אבל כל מישהו בעסירון העליון עושה ים בכסף ים
בים בכסף במיוחד מה זה קריפטו עכשיו, אתה מסתכל, ואתה אומר, אם הם מתקדמים בקצב שיש להם
אינסנטיב של עשרות מיליונים לקבוצה של חמישה עד שבעה אנשים לעשות משהו ויש כאלה אלפים
אז ברור שכאילו מתקדמים מהר.
הם קונים exploitation וקונים vulnerabilities וסוחרים את החוקרים הכי טובים ועושים מלא מלא
עבודה.
אז אתה צריך להתקדם מולם.
עכשיו, החברות שאנחנו עובדים מטמטה מצד השני, אומרת, עזורתי בשקט, אנחנו לא יכולים להשקיע ככה
בביסייבר, יש לנו, ביזנס מי שלנו לעבוד.
אז אתה יודע, קודם הם לא קוראים להם שום דבר נוראי.
הם רק אומרים, תעשה את המינימום האפשרי כדי לשרוד את האומיום.
ואז שקורה איזשהו אירוע בטעות,
ולצערי רב אנחנו מציעים בעולם שזה קורה לכל אחד פעם בכמה שנים אין מה לעשות פתאום החברה עוברת
את זה הזוהר וכולם פתאום מההתחלה צריכים לבנות את כל הדברים מההתחלה ואז אתה אומר לצחק טוב
עשינו הרבה מאוד טעויות כי ישקענו פה ופה התמקדנו בגידול שלנו עכשיו צריך להחזור לחזור החוב
ולהתקן מלא דברים אז השוק עצמו כל הזמן דינמי פשוט בצורה מדהימה
לגמרי נמצא להסתכלות אחורה מה הצעק הכי טוב שאתה נותן לי הזמי סייבר שם בתחילת בריקם
תמוד ששאלו אותי את השאלה הזאתי תראה השוק עצמו משתנה ומי שהולך להיכנס לשוק שהוא רבוי
במתחרים קיימים בלי איזה שהוא clear differentiator
‫המחירה אולי סב-אופטימלית.
דיפרנצ'ייטור זה דבר מאוד מאוד חשוב דיפרנצ'ייטור מצד שני בשוק הסייבר לא מרזיק הרבה זמן
דיפרנצ'ייטור מרזיק תשעה חודשים, חמש עשרה חודשים, זהו אחרי זה לכל המתחרים שלך יש אנשים
חכמים כמו שלך ואם אתה מצליח הם יעתיקו משך נורא מהר אנחנו רואים פיצ'רים שלנו אצל המתחרים
זה חנופה נורא נחמדה שכאילו מעתיקים איתנו, אבל מה שזה מלמד אותנו, בסופו של דבר אתה מוציא
משהו וכל השאר מעתיקים.
זה מה זה, אז אתה צריך לחשוב פעם אחת על דיפרנט שאתה אמיתי ופעם שנייה על זה שתריאת דורש מלא
מלא לאנשים אם יש לך שחקנים כעמים בשוק אתה צריך לחשוב איך תעוקף אותם בשלוש שנים ואם נראה לך
שיש להם עומק טכנולוגי אמיתי שאתה יכול לעקוף אתם בשלוש שנים
אולי זה לא התחום עבורך, אולי צריך לעשות משהו אחר אז אתמול דיברתי עם מישהו שניסה לחשוב איך
הוא נכנס לאחד בטרווים בסייבר ואמרת לו תקשיב אלא הם כן יש לך זווית מאוד מאוד מאוד ברורה מה
אתם יוכל לעשות שונה מה שהם עושים
אתה הולך לסרוף עשרות מיליון דולרים להדביק את הפער מולם ויהיה לך קשה מאוד בתהליך המחירה.
נו
אז לגמרי לחשב על הדיפרנציאטור, לחשב על מה עושה אותך מיוחדים.
בלי זה, אולי לא בכך שווה לקפוץ אל האזמות הזאתי, נחכות לאזמות הבאה.
כן, אני חושב שזה באמת, אני מדבר על אחד גם הדברים שעולים פה, לא מעט, אלמד התחרותיות של
האקוסיסטם הזה.
זאת אומרת, יש תחרות גדולה בכל עולם תוכן, אבל בסייבר, אני חושב שבין היתר בעיקר בגלל הצורת
מחירה, בגלל גם איך שהאקוסיסטם הזה עובד ובגלל שבסוף צוותים של חברות סייבר, בנכון הם
מורכבים, הם אנשים מאוד מוכשרים ומאוד חכמים, היכולת
להתבונן ולראות מה עובד אצל השכן ולקבל החלטה של להעתיק לשכפל היא החלטה שאפשר לקבל אותה מאוד
מהר והיא לא עלה הרבה
‫כן, בדיוק.
האינוביישן עולה ‫הרבה יותר מאשר השלב הראשון ‫של באמת לעשות את זה.
‫ואז אתה מוצא את עצמך במצב ‫שאם אתה לא יודע כל הזמן ‫איך אתה יוצר את האינוביישן הבא, ‫זה
בעיה.
‫זה בדיוק המקום שבו הרבה ‫מוצגתים מוצאים את עצמם, ‫שבו הם היו ראשונים, ‫ופתאום בא מתחרה
שהוא צעיר מהם ‫בכמה שנים והוא אוכל להם את השוק.
ראינו את זה לכונה כמה וכמה פעמים.
לגמרי, לגמרי ואני חושב שזה יכול לתסכל חלק וזה יכול מאוד מרגש לצוג מסוים של יזמים שרוצים
להיות בתוך המרוץ הזה ולנצח אותו
אז אם אתה בצד שאוכלים לאחרים, זה מאוד מרגש, אם אתה בצד שאוכלים לא, קצת פחות.
נכון, נכון, אבל אני חושב שזה גם חלק מהעניין זה, זה לא סטטיסט, זאת אומרת, זה לא, לא, זה לא,
כלומר, אתה יכול להיות לאורך המסע בשני הצדדים, אני מניח, ולחוות את שניהם.
אתה יכול לצמי שנים, זה חלק מהעניין, אתה כל הזמן צריך להתאווית.
זה חלק מהתקשיב.
חשוב מומנטום בתחום הזה?
קריטי, קריטי, קריטי.
בסופו של דבר, מומנטום קובע לך בצורה מאוד משמעותית כמה אתה מייצ.
זה מאוד מאוד מאוד מאוד חשוב.
אם אין לך את המומנטום, שאתה אומר, יש לי לקוחות סמכים ומדברים, ונמצאים איתי בוובינרים ו...
יהיה לך מאוד קשה.
לגמרי.
ניצן, מה זה תודה שנתת לי את הזמן שהצטרפת עליי?
סופר מעריך את זה, שיהיה מלמה לבצעכם הוקס סקיורטי.
אתה יודע, בסוף עולם האפלקיישן דבלופמנט, הוא בעולם הדבלופמנט באופן כללי, הוא עובד כל כך בטע
פחות וכולם נהיו סופטוור אנג'נירים כמעט היום, נראה לי.
וזה רק, אני חושב שכל השאלה של איך בסוף אנחנו בונים בצורה חכמה ואיך אנחנו...
וקאפל דיחה עם ה-Alert Fatigue שקיים ואיך מביאים סקיורטי אמיתי בתהליך של הכתיבה זה עניין לא
טריוויאלי בכלל.
אז תודה שגידת את הזמן.
תודה רבה
תודה רבה ניצן.
תודה.